THAT MANDATORY HEARING ON
PROPOSED BALLOT INITIATIVE
CALLED THE DIVISION OF
CALIFORNIA INTO THREE STATES.
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE AND
THIS IS A JOINT HEARING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
IN THE SET SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION HAPPY
TO WELCOME.
A COLLEAGUE SENATOR BILL DODD
WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE.
TO US.
TO THIS HEARING HERE TODAY. ACT
IT'S CALIFORNIA LAW THAT EVERY
BALLOT MEASURE ONCE IT GETS AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
VOTES AND PRIOR TO A HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE DAYS I BELIEVE IT IS
FROM THE ELECTION. WHICH IN THIS
CASE MEANS.
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HOLDS A HEARING ON A
BALLOT MEASURE THAT IS TO BE PUT
ON THE BALLOT BY SIGNATURE.
THIS BALLOT MEASURE IT QUALIFIES
AT LEAST FOR THAT IT IS.
EVIDENTY GUARDED AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE PRCENT OF THE
REQUIRED SIGNATURES SO WE NEED
TO HOLD THIS HEARING HERE SOON.
AND TODAY WAS THE DAY THAT WE
SCHEDULED AT THE HEARING ABOUT
DISAPPOINTED TO REPORT THAT THE
PROPONENTS THOUGH INVITED
DECLINED TO COME.
AND IT'S TOO BAD THAT I'M NOT
QUITE SURE WHY.
THEY PROPOSED A BALLOT MEASURE
SPENT ALL THAT MONEY TWO QUICK
SIGNATURES AND REFUSED TO BE
HERE TO TO EVEN BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT. SINCE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A PUBLIC
HEARING ABOUT A BALLOT MEASURE
AND GIVEN THE.
ECONOMIC AND THE LEGAL AND THE
SOCIAL CONSEQUENCES OF. BREAKING
THE STATE INTO THREE SEPARATE
STATES.
THEY TO NOT HAVE A PROPONENT
HERE IS A LITTLE FRUSTRATING
AND.
IN MY VIEW A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISING BUT NEVERTHELESS WE
ARE OBLIGATED TO MOVE FORWARD
WE'RE GOING HOLD HEARINGS WE'VE
GIVEN EVERYBODY AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO TO COME AND
JOIN US AND.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO.
THAT THIS IN ARE APPROPRIATE
WAYS AND THEN BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD SENATOR YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE YEAH
BRIEFLY AT FIRST LIKE TO THANK
THE. CHAIRMAN STONE IN THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR PUTTING THE
SONGS PRETTY BUSY.
TIME SO WELL KEEP IT BRIEF I TOO
AM DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT
PROPONENTS OF THE INITIATIVE
COULD NOT BE HERE TO DISCUSS
WHAT THEY FEEL ARE. IMPORTANT
BENEFITS TO BREAKING UP THE
STATE.
INTO THREESEPARATE STATES
HOWEVER I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE LA
ARE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE OUR
COMMITTEES WITH INSIGHT ON. HOW
THIS PROCESS WOULD WORK AND THE
MANY CHALLENGES?
THAT THIS INITIATIVE
I PRESENTS.
A LET ME THANK IN ADVANCE THE
WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE. IF THE
LA A O. COULD COME FORWARD NOW
SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN THIS
HEARING OKAY LET'S INVITE A PAIR
OF THE THE WHOLE PANEL. WE HAVE
AND HAULING SAID SENIOR FISCAL
OPEN UP AND POLICY ANALYST FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
TIM DRAPER WAS INVITED WHOSE THE
INITIATIVE PROPONENTS AND LAUREN
QUE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR COMEDIAN.
AND EDUCATION AND INITIATIVE OF
OPPONENTS.
AND ONCE WE HAVE THE SPEAKERS
THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE WELCOME TO
SIT THERE BUT I WOULD JUST MOVE
THAT.
YEAH.
WE WILL THEN HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
CLOSING COMMENTS.
AND MOVE ON WITH THEIR DAY RIGHT
PLEASE FROM THE LA OUT. I THINK
YOU CHEN MEMBERS AND HOLLINGS
HAD FROM LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
I'M SO ME JUST BEGIN WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AROUND OUR
OFFICE'S ROLE. IN THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS AND THEN ALSO IN THIS
HEARING SPECIFICALLY.
SO PROPOSITION NINE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR GAVE OUR OFFICE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONDUCT
IMPARTIAL ANALYSIS OF ALL
STATEWIDE INITIATIVES.
AND AS SUCH ARE WE DO NOT TAKE
A POSITION OR OFFER ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON.
PROPOSITION ANALYSES THAT IT
MAY BE A BIT DIFFERENT.
IN THIS HEARINGS CONTACTS JOB
VERSES.
BOB VERSUS OUR ROLE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WHERE WE DO OFFER
ANALYSIS AND COMMENTARY.
IN ADDITION I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THIS INITIATIVE
INVOLVES A NUMBER OF LEGAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTIONS.
THESE ARE YOU KNOW PARTICULARLY
COMPLEX IN THIS CONTEXT WE ARE
NOT LAWYERS ALTHOUGH WE DID
CONSULT WITH LAWYERS AS WE PUT
TOGETHER OUR ANALYSIS.
SO IT MAY BE DIFFICULT FOR US
TO IT.
YOU KNOW ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MORE THORNY COMPLEX LEGAL ISSUES
THAT ARE POSED BY THIS
INITIATIVE.
SO.
THIS INITIATIVE PROPOSES
PUTTING CALIFORNIA INTO THREE
SEPARATE STATES
BEFORE I TALK ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY WHAT BE JUST BOB
BRIEFLY ADDRESS SOME. SOME LEGAL
BACKGROUND HERE.
I SO FIRST ON INITIATIVE
PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA GIVES THE VOTERS THE
POWER TO EXERCISE SOME BUT NOT
ALL OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
POWERS THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS FOR EXAMPLE VOTERS CAN
CREATE AND I CHANGE LAWS THROUGH
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS BUT THEY
CANNOT EXERCISE OTHER
LEGISLATIVE POWERS FOR EXAMPLE
ON COURTS HAVE FOUND THAT THE
VOTERS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
EXERCISE LEGISLATURE'S POWER TO
ADVISE. OF THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
PROCESS.
SECOND.
ON THE U. S. CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION SO ARTICLE FOUR OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES THE PROCESS UP BY WHICH
A NEW STATE COULD BE ADMITTED TO
THE UNION EITHER BY SPLITTING
FROM AN EXISTING STATE OR OR A
WHOLLY NEW STATE IN GENERAL.
AND HISTORICALLY FOUR STATES
HAVE BEEN ADMITTED TO THE UNION
AFTER BEING SPLIT FROM EXISTING
STATES. IN EACH OF THESE CASES.
UNDER THE REQUIREMENTS OF
ARTICLE FOR.
BOTH CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL IS
REQUIRED AND THEN THE APPROVAL
OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE'S INVOLVED IT'S
REQUIRED.
IN EACH OF THE FOUR HISTORICAL
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATIVE BODY WAS
THE ENTITY THAT PROVIDED THAT
APPROVAL.
AND THERE IS NO CLEAR
HISTORICAL PRECEDENT OR COURT
RULING THAT SAYS THAT THE VOTERS
CAN PROVIDE THAT APPROVAL THAT'S
NECESSARY UNDER ARTICLE FORM.
SO THIS INITIATIVE PROPOSES TO
SPLIT CALIFORNIA INTO THREE
STATES.
THESE NEW STATES WOULD BE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHICH WOULD SPAN FROM THE
OREGON BORDER DOWN ON TO SANTA
CRUZ THEN THERE WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA WHICH WOULD BE MOST
OF THE COASTAL STATES I'VE ALL
ALL OF THE COASTAL STATES FROM
MODERATE TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES.
AND THEN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHICH WOULD STRETCH FROM ORANGE
AND SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THROUGH.
MUCH OF THE REST OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
THE MEASURE ALSO AIMS TO PROVIDE
THE REQUIRED STATE LEGISLATIVE
CONSENT ARDEN UNDER.
ARTICLE FOUR OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION. SO I'M
CLEARLY THERE ARE SEVERAL LEGAL
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED BY THIS
MEASURE FIRST ON UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTIONAL SIDE WHETHER.
THIS IS.
ALLOWABLE.
.
USE OF PASSWORD ALLOWABLE
APPROVAL PROCESS UNDER ARTICLE
FOR THE UNITED STATES
CONSTITUTION AND THAT ALSO UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONAL
PERSPECTIVE THE QUESTION WOULD
BE WHETHER THIS IT IS AN
ALLOWABLE USE OF THE VOTERS
INITIATIVE POWER.
THOSE ARE BOTH ISSUES.
THE COURTS THEMSELVES WOULD
HAVE TO RESOLVE
SO EVEN IF THE MEASURES APPROVED
BY VOTERS AND THEN APPROVED BY
COURTS.
WE FIND THAT IT DOES NOT HAVE
ANY DIRECT FISCAL EFFECTS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL
IN ORDER TO TAKE EFFECT.
CONGRESS COULD DECIDE OUGHT NOT
TO APPROVE THE REQUEST COULD
APPROVE THE REQUEST AS PROPOSED
OR CONGRESS COULD APPROVE A
DIFFERENCE BUT OF THE STATE STAY
INTO TWO. DIFFERENT PIECES.
IN THAT CASE HE WOULD RETURN TO
CALIFORNIA FOR APPROVAL BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO FINALLY I AM IF THE SPLIT DID
OCCUR SO IF VOTERS APPROVED IT
BOB IT WAS ALLOWED BY THE COURTS
AND CONGRESS PER.
APPROVED IT AS PROPOSED
THEN.
THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY AND LEGAL QUESTIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE TO
ADDRESS.
BOTH THE EXISTING STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S OF THE NEW STATES
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS
AROUND HOW TO DIVIDE
CALIFORNIA'S ARM. ASSETS AND
LIABILITIES HOW TO DIVIDE ITS
EXISTING PENSION DIED ITS DEBT
TO EXTERNAL BOND HOLDERS.
AS WELL AS MANY OTHER COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
RESOLVED BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND I'D ALSO POINT OUT
THE BACK ON PAPER I THINK GOES
THROUGH PRETTY EXHAUSTIVE LIST
OF SOME OF THE OTHER.
LOCATIONS THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
SORTED OUT.
TO CATCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
A CONSULTANT SAID THANK YOU FOR
A INVITING ME A AS YOU KNOW THAT
I'M LAURIN QUE I'M PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
COMMERCE AND EDUCATION OR A
THINK TANK AFFILIATED WITH
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
UP OUR BOARD CAL CHAMBER BOARD
LAST MONTH VOTED TO OPPOSE THE
THREE STATES MEASURE FOR THREE
REASONS.
DISINGENUOUS IT'S
DISTRACTING.
AND IF IT'S IMPLEMENTED IT'S
DANGEROUS.
SO FOR ALL OUR SUCCESSES IN IN
CALIFORNIAN FOR THE WONDER THAT
WERE HELD.
GLOBALLY.
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE MANY PROBLEMS.
AND NOBODY KNOWS THIS BETTER
THAN YOU.
YOU HEAR ABOUT IT FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FROM.
ARE YOUR COLLEAGUES AND FROM.
A US IN THE.
AMONG THE ORGANIZED INTERESTS.
BUT FOR ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN HERE
FOR MORE THAN A WEEK AND A HALF.
YOU REALIZE THAT IF YOU'RE
SINCERELY COMMITTED TO FIXING
ANY OF THESE PROBLEMS.
YOU FIX THE PROBLEM.
DIVISION INTO THREE STATES
DOESN'T FIX ANY PROBLEMS.
IT MAKES ALL OF OUR PROBLEMS
OBJECTIVELY WORSE.
IN THE HOPE THAT SOMEONE WHO'S
MORE ENLIGHTENED AND MORE
PRACTICAL THAN THE AUTHOR.
WILL EVENTUALLY COME AROUND AND
REALLY FINALLY FIX THE.
SO I WANT TO GIVE YOU A A
PARTIAL LIST OF THE.
BILLS THAT THE PROPONENT.
HAS IDENTIFIED ON HIS WEBSITE
THAT BESET CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA RANKS LAST IN THE
COUNTRY IN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES NEAR THE BOTTOM
IN HIGH PRIORITY SUBJECTS LIKE
MATH CALIFORNIA'S HIGHWAYS
BRIDGES FREEWAYS AND CITY ROADS.
ARE RANKED AMONG THE POOREST IN
THE NATION
CALIFORNIANS PAY THE HIGHEST
TAXES IN THE NATION AND YET OUR
TAX DOLLARS ARE MISMANAGED IN
EVERY WAY.
THE CURRENT OVERCROWDING AND.
UNDER FUNDED PRISON SYSTEM IS
FAILING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
REGIONS REQUIRE GOVERNMENT
ATTENTION THE TO SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED TO ADDRESS.
THE AREA'S NEEDS.
SO FROM HIS WEBSITE
WE'RE YOU CAN QUIBBLE LISTA
DEGREE BUT YES THESE ARE ALL
PROBLEMS THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON.
EVERYDAY THAT WE TALK ABOUT.
THAT THERE'S A BIG CONVERSATION
GOES ON IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
THESE.
A PROBLEMS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA VOTER STATE AS FOR
THIS INITIATIVE THOUGH IT DOES
NOTHING TO ADVANCE A SOLUTION
ANY OF THESE PROBLEMS IT DOESN'T
ADD A NEW TEACHER. IT DOESN'T
REFORM ANY SCHOOL REGULATIONS.
IT DOESN'T. ARE AND ANY MONEY TO
THE ROADS IT DOESN'T TAKE A
SINGLE A CAR OFF OF THE.
HIGHWAYS
IT DOESN'T A AT ANY PRISON BUT
BEDS MODIFY.
ANY SENTENCES.
OF RAZOR REDUCE ANY TAXES ARE
CENTRAL CHALLENGE IS TO.
RECONCILE THE PLURALISTIC
DEMANDS OF DIVERSE INTERESTS.
IN A DYNAMIC NATION STATE.
AND ADVANCE THE OVERALL WELFARE
FOR CITIZENRY THIS INITIATIVE.
REQUIRES THAT SURRENDER.
TO THIS TEST IS A BETTER OPTION.
THEN RISING TO THAT CHALLENGE.
IT'S DISINGENUOUS TO SUGGEST A
VOTERS.
THAT THE MEASURE IS A SOLUTION
TO OF VARIETY OF HILLS WHEN IT
ACCOMPLISHES NO MORE. THAN TRIED
DRAWING TWO MORE LINES ON THE
MAP OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO RATHER THAN SEEKING TO SOLVE
THE REAL PROBLEMS BEFORE AS THE
MEASURE INSTEAD CREATES AN
ENTIRELY NEW SUITE OF PROBLEMS
TO DISTRACT AND CONSUME VOTERS.
POLITICAL LEADERS LIKE
YOURSELVES CONCERNED CITIZENS AN
ORDINARY RESIDENTS.
AT.
CALIFORNIANS.
OF US SADLY DON'T.
ALWAYS EXHIBIT A ROBUST
BANDWIDTH FOR CONSIDERING
STATE ISSUES.
WHAT WAS THE TURNOUT AT
YESTERDAY'S
PRIMARY ELECTION?
WE WAS EVEN FORTY PERCENT OF.
I'M NOT SURE.
HOPEFULLY WILL BE MORE IN IN
NOVEMBER.
.
BUT.
TRULY THE LAST THING WE NEED ON
THE BALLOT WE GET INVOLVED IN A
LOT ABOUT STATEWIDE BALLOT
MEASURES
PROBABLY.
PROBABLY NO.
THE LAST THING WE NEED ON THIS
BALLOT.
IS A MEASURE OF ITS INFAMOUS.
SOLELY FOR ITS AUDACITY.
OUR LIMITED CAPACITY TO DISCUSS
IMPORTANT CONSEQUENTIAL ISSUES
LIKE HOUSING AND POVERTY AND
HOMELESSNESS TAXES
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE'LL BE CROWDED OUT BY A
POINTLESS SPECULATION AND
DEBATE.
OVER AN UNLIKELY EVENT THAT
NOBODY IN ANY RESPONSIBLE
POSITIONS EVER SUGGESTED.
EVEN IF YOU AGREE THE
CALIFORNIA'S MUST MAKE
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES TO OUR
GOVERNMENT SUCH AS.
SUCH AN EXISTENTIAL CHANGE
SHOULD NOT BE THE SUBJECT OF A
SIMPLISTIC BALLOT MEASURE.
AS OUR. REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S SAID THIS
IS.
OF BALLOT MEASURES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY.
THE.
CORRECT OR APPROVED.
OF METHOD FOR EVERY OF MATTER
YES THE PEOPLE STAND IN THE
SHOES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
WHEN THEY VOTE ON. OUR
INITIATIVES.
BUT THEY CANNOT REVISE THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY CANNOT MAKE WHOLESALE
CHANGES.
THAT.
EVEN EVEN BY OF OF BALLOT
INITIATIVE THAT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REVISION PROCESS.
IN THE CONSTITUTION NOT COURSE
WE NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE SO WHO
KNOWS.
BUT THERE ARE THAT THERE ARE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING IS MORE
APPROPRIATE IF YOU WERE.
SO DELUDED AS TO THINK IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
EXPLORED. OF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ITSELF SHOULD DO OR
YOU SHOULD HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REVISION COMMISSION TO CONSIDER.
SO FINALLY.
AND SOMEWHAT RELUCTANTLY ALL
SPEND A FEW MINUTES DWELLING ON
THE PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS
OF BREAKING CALIFORNIAN TO
PIECES.
THE.
CHALLENGES ARE STARTING TO SAY
THE LEAST FOR REDISTRIBUTION OF
STATE ASSETS ASSIGNMENT OF STATE
RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT TO
MENTION.
ADDRESSING THE INHERENT
INEQUITIES THAT WILL ARISE FROM
ARBITRARY GEOGRAPHICAL DIVISION
OF ECONOMIC FINANCIAL PHYSICAL.
AND CULTURAL PATRIMONY HAS.
AND IT LOOKED LIKE YOU I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND. THE STAFF REPORT OR
STAFF REPORTS THAT WERE OF DONE
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S.
IS THE PRICE OF FROM THERE.
THEIR THOROUGH.
BUT FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE JUST A
SAMPLING OF WHAT WE.
WHAT YOU WOULD FACE?
SHOULD THIS INITIATIVE PASS AND
SHOULD THE CONGRESS AGREED TO
SET MOTION DIVISION TO THREE
CALIFORNIANS.
FIRST OF ALL. WITH WITH WITH.
RESPECT TO THE.
.
TO THE.
STATEMENT THAT THERE'S NO DIRECT
COST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TRUE THERE'S NO.
SUBSTANTIAL DIRECT COST OF
SENDING A LETTER TO CONGRESS
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT THIS.
MEASURE.
.
DOES.
BUT IT'S IT'S DISINGENUOUS AND
REALLY A DISSERVICE TO THE TO
THE VOTERS
TO.
TO TO NOT.
.
A LAYOUT AT LEAST WHAT THE
INITIAL COSTS WOULD BE IF THIS
WAS TO BE ADOPTED AND.
I'LL JUST SIT HERE AND AND.
AND.
REQUEST THAT WHEN YOU DO
PUBLISHER FINAL FISCAL ANALYSIS
THAT YOU DO A CONSIDER SOME OF
THESE.
BECAUSE THE VOTERS TO READ THE
BALLOT PAMPHLET THAT'S ONE OF
THE PLACES WHERE.
THEY DO GET INFORMATION.
.
BUT IF THE IF THE IT IF THE
CONGRESS WERE TO APPROVE SUCH A.
.
THE PROCESS.
WELL FIRST THE ORIGINAL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WILL BE OBLIGATED TO SPEND TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
ESTABLISHMENT OF.
THREE CONVENTIONS
IN EACH OF THE NEW
PROTESTATIONS.
TO DIVIDE THE CONSTITUTION AND A
SET OF LAWS.
THIS WOULD REQUIRE DELEGATE
SELECTION PROCESS MEETING STAFF
LEGAL SUPPORT NOT REACH COURSE
THE STATE WOULD.
AS YOU SUGGESTED THE STATE
WOULD HAVE TO DEFEND.
AGAINST VIGOROUSLY LITIGATION ON
THE VALIDITY OF THE MEASURE.
ALLEN MANY ASPECTS OF THE
PROCESS THAT COMES OUT OF IT.
SECOND EACH OF THE THREE NEW
STATES.
BECOME START OF VENTURES
REQUIRING.
ELECTION OF NEW STATEWIDE AND
LEGISLATIVE OFFICIALS
APPOINTMENT OF NEW EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OFFICERS NEW RECRUITMENT
AND HIRING STATE OF STAFF
APPOINTMENT OF NEW.
PRISON GRANTEES
ADOPTION OF NEW CODES GOVERNMENT
CODE CIVIL CODE.
TAX CODE CRIMINAL QUOTE ALL OF
THAT.
MAYBE NEW CENSUS.
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
AND THEN THE FUN BEGINS THAT'S
THAT'S JUST ALL THE BASIC
MINIMUM TO GET THE STRUCTURE IN
PLACE.
.
AGAIN I POINT TO THE
STAFF REPORT WHICH GOES INTO.
GREAT DETAIL ON THIS BUT.
BUT JUST OF.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT SOME
OF THE KEY.
QUESTIONS ABOUT DIVIDING THE
ASSETS AND LIABILITIES OF ALL
CALIFORNIA.
WOULD INCLUDE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS TUITION
POLICIES FOR THE INCUMBENT
STUDENTS.
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ESTIMATED
THAT THE COST OF THE STUDENTS
FOR.
AS A RESULT OF OUT OF STATE
TUITION COULD BE IN THE ORDER
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR PRISONERS
DOMICILED IN ONE STATE.
WHO WERE COMMITTED FROM ANOTHER?
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FOR PAYMENT
OF WATER POWER AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSETS LOCATED
ONE STATE.
SERVE THE RESIDENTS OF ANOTHER
STATE.
OF COURSE MOST NOTORIOUSLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
MOST OF THE NEW. CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S THE.
LA BASED
STATE.
AND MUCH OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLIES ARE
LOCATED WOULD BE LOCATED IN A
DIFFERENT STATE MAY HAVE TO
TRAVERSE EVEN A SECOND STATE TO
REACH OUR ULTIMATE DESTINATION.
OF.
EACH NEW LEGISLATURE A
CONSTITUTIONAL CONVENTION WOULD
HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT OF OUR
POLTICAL LEGACY TO ADOPT TO
REJECT WHAT ABOUT PROP THIRTEEN.
THE FORTIETH BIRTHDAY OR PROP
NINETY EIGHT.
WILL THERE BE REAPPORTIONMENT
COMMISSIONS DEATH PENALTY
WOULD ANY OF THE HARD FOUGHT
POLITICAL BATTLES THAT OCCURRED
OVER THE DECADES.
IN BALLOT MEASURES.
WHETHER REFLECTING A.
.
PREVAILING VICTORY OF THE LEFT
OR THE RIGHT.
OF WOULD THEY SURVIVE INTO THESE
NEW REGIMES.
AND THEN FINALLY WITH REGARD TO.
THIS INTRIGUING AND.
BIZARRE STATEMENT THAT.
.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE FAILS TO
REACH RESOLUTION OF DIVISION A
TRANSFORMATION OF CALIFORNIA
WITHIN TWELVE MONTHS.
THEN DEBTS ARE DISTRIBUTED AMONG
NEWLY CREATED STATES.
BASED ON POPULATION
PROPORTIONALLY SO JUST TO
DECONSTRUCT THIS.
IF SAY HALF OF THE G. O. BONDS.
THE GEO BOND DEBT FOR SCHOOLS.
LAWLER CHIO BONDS.
IS IN THE NEW CALIFORNIA NEW LA
BASED.
WITH THE OTHER TWO STATES WITH
EACH OF WOULD HAVE TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT.
OF THE SCHOOLS.
BE REQUIRED TO PAY A THIRD OF
THE DEBT AND LIKEWISE SAFE FOR
BUT PENSION.
OBLIGATIONS.
THE NEW CALIFORNIA HAS TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE UC CAMPUSES AND
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE UC.
MEDICAL CENTERS BUT WOULD
RESIDENTS OF THE NEW CALIFORNIA
TO BE A THIRD.
OF THE PENSION.
DEBT.
I DON'T KNOW.
WELL AS YOU CAN SEE THIS
EXERCISE MOVES QUICKLY FROM A
SERIOUS POLICY ANALYSIS TO
PARLOR GAME.
A AND WITH THAT ALL.
I'VE PROBABLY SPENT MORE THAN
THEY SHOULD TO DIGNIFY THIS
MEASURE.
WITH THE. WITH THE DISCUSSION OF
A BUT BUT THERE YOU GO HAPPY TO
RESPOND AND.
I THINK IF.
QUESTIONS.
VERY QUICKLY
GREAT THANK YOU I'M GONNA. THAT
OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS.
IT'S HEARING.
ALRIGHT SING NONE BRING IT BACK
FOR.
FINAL COMMENT CENTER.
I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU BEING
HERE I THINK YOU.
ARTICULATED YOUR POSITION IS
VERY VERY WELL AND.
TIME WILL TELL THANK YOU YEAH.
I I TWIST WAS POINTED OUT TO ME
THAT CURRENTLY.
VOTER TURNOUT IN OUR YESTERDAY'S
ELECTION STANDS AT TWENTY ONE
POINT EIGHT PERCENT WAS.
OF COURSE THERE HAVE TO DEAL
BALLOTS AND OTHERS TO BE COUNTED
SO OVER THE NEXT MONTH WILL.
THAT WILL HOPEFULLY GO UP
SUBSTANTIALLY BANG IT ONLY HAS
SO FAR TO GO. PRETTY POOR TURNED
OUT TO YOUR POINTS.
EXACTLY AND I WILL JUST HAVE TO
SAY THAT.
PATTERN TWENTY LEGISLATORS WHO
ARE HERE AND YES WE FIGHT FOR A
DISTRICTS THAT WE FIGHT FOR
CONSTITUENTS BUT. WE ALSO HAVE A
MUCH BROADER SENSE OF WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT
AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE.
AND SO TO THINK ABOUT BREAKING
THAT UP AND BREAKING IT DOWN
WITH.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT ACOSTA
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
IS SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK
THIS LEGISLATORS NOT A QUESTION
I DON'T THINK INCOME OF THIS
LEGISLATURE FOR THOSE REASONS
AND FOR THE REASONS THAT WERE.
THAT WERE ARTICULATED SOLD BE
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IF THIS GETS ON THE BALLOT.
AND.
WHAT THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
REALLY WOULD HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
IT BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S NOT OUR?
QUESTION IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE RESPONDED TO
FEDERALLY AND FORTUNATELY OR
UNFORTUNATELY THEY SEEM TO BE
INCAPABLE OF DOING MUCH OF THAT.
BUT A WHAT WE SAID TO THEM. WHO
KNOWS AND WE ARE YOU KNOW WE WE
ARE GOVERNING AND YOU YOU POINT
OUT THAT DIVIDES AND SOME OF THE
POLITICAL QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
IN THE FIGHTS THAT WE HAVE?
AND EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE STRONG
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITIES WE ARE
GOVERNING WE ARE GOVERNING IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY PRIMARILY IN BOTH
HOUSES AND HAVE OF VARIETY OF
PERSPECTIVES AT THE TABLE AS WE
DO POLICY AND. HOW HOW COULD
ANYONE WANT TO BREAK?
THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE BREAK IT UP THEN
THEY MOVE TO SOMETHING ELSE SO
I KNOW I THAT IS.
THIS PRIORITY WITH THAT.
I APPRECIATE SENATOR YOU BEING
HERE PROCEED EVERYBODY BEING
HERE APPRECIATE THE THE PANEL
COME FORWARD AND LAY THIS OUT A
LITTLE BIT AND THE GREAT WORK
THAT WAS DONE TO.
BUT AT WHAT THEIR POTENTIAL
IMPLICATIONS ARE WILL WE ILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND WE ARE
ADJOURNED